that's why like i feel like now people
think that they
they're owed more than what they
actually deserve you know like there's a
lot of people who are pricing themselves
you think more p you think people feel
entitled now i think
for me like i don't overprice myself
ever i just want the opportunity and i
think the money comes after the
opportunity
after you prove yourself exactly he's a
smart man absolutely i did that
for nothing my first two or three pro
fights right
but listen after that then they got to
pay for your service
your world-class fighter when i say a
world-class fight fighter the fighter
entertaining the crowd yeah you know
what i mean
everybody's fighting people they're your
fans my mind should get your work
my first eight fights i didn't make no
money i fought in mexico
the first seven it's not about money i
didn't make anything but getting the
platform
exactly the experience yeah then the
money comes in
mike's first fight man he got paid for a
hundred bucks yeah that's right that's
yeah i'd seen
somebody my mentor made it out of his
pocket
it's on the [ __ ] page jesus the
prediction is enough for me to buy my
little weed
that was cool oh yeah back back then you
were hot boxing back then too much
every now and then so i've seen like
i've seen so much documentaries about
you
how was it how did you grow up how was
it growing up in brownsville
it's tough yeah challenging tough gotta
worry about [ __ ] [ __ ] you
and that
people killing you [ __ ] trying
to rob you
whatever whatever you can do to a human
being they'll do it
yeah yeah but that made you tougher
mentally right
i don't know that's what people say it
does
maybe it damaged you too and the other
thing i want to
elaborate on that mike hold on hear this
hear this damage you maybe
think um if anybody ever knew this
happened to you that [ __ ] hate your
guts
yeah so you gotta be um
maybe you have to overdo your
masculinity to make them
never believe it yeah and that's how a
lot of animals are born
they've been taken advantage of yeah
it happens in the animal kingdom too
mike yeah and they don't want people to
know that they turn into animals yeah
i believe so yeah yeah the other thing i
wanted to ask you about
you said that when you're a little kid
and you're training with custom model
that he would
hypnotize you i don't know if he'd
hypnotize you how would
that made you into like who you are
reaching your subconscious mm-hmm
you know that most of us know that our
subconscious is
our subconscious is uh our power out of
you know
not in check just waiting for a signal
mm-hmm
and our consciousness gives it the
signal yeah
not right away but we constantly act for
it
yeah over time yeah it's constantly act
for it's almost like a
affirmation it's a guy named emil kawai
he created i'm getting better every day
i am beautiful
i am magnificent i am invincible
i am a god and he he created that you're
saying wonderful things to yourself
every morning and every night in your
life are changing
and it shows that it happens to the
majority of the people so that's what
people have been doing most of their
life believing in themselves believing
in a mystic god
yeah more so than the religion that we
believe in
yeah do you do that david do you or does
your dad work the mental stuff or is
that something uh
you've always been special man well for
me i try to like
you know just different [ __ ] that that
doesn't really involve
physical activity you know like um
meditating
stuff like that you know i'm a big fan
of like subconscious stuff and you know
like what you just said telling yourself
you're getting better you're getting
better you're the best i'm the best
and stuff like that and i mean i feel
like it has worked for me um
obviously i'm not where i want to be but
i feel like you know i keep doing it
you know where you are and that's yeah
you're far from where you want to be
how far can a fat kid like that get
right here
really think about it i don't really
really think about it
but um like i feel like it's building my
confidence it's built my confidence and
like i just want to shoot for the stars
man and i just wanna i always tell
people like this guy
you got a champion mentality your
attitude you're a champion before you
even became
champion yeah and i thought that's the
subconscious your champion before you
don't become
champion if you're not already champion
and you fight for the championship
you're not gonna win
you know you gotta be champion before
you fight for the chip you have to have
the lifestyle of a champion
and that that and in return you received
the championship
you can't think of yourself as a
contender yeah
you can and you you notice like the
minute the time that we're spending here
mike
this kid's attitude is different mike we
had a lot of people on the show but
you can see you can feel the
transparency of hunger that hey i'm here
dude
i am here and i am going to fight
anybody to put in front of me
i mean he's here but he's ordained by
god to be here he's adorned to be the
ruler
it's just he can't help it you think
you're doing this
i know you don't think you're really
direct navigating your [ __ ] i feel like
a lot of the things that happened to me
that i've been blessed
you know and everything has just
happened this is all god yeah
exactly exactly i feel like everything
that has happened to me is all god's
plan and i feel that's why i want to be
a good person too i try to help out as
much people as i can and
try to give as much advice as i can
because i feel like you know if i'm a
[ __ ] or i treat people like [ __ ]
then my life is going to go to [ __ ]
or if i'm a good person good
opportunities are going to come to me
you can't be
you can't be good unless you're a little
bad yeah it
is that's why i got the ring i saw when
i'm in
the ring i'm a bad dude you know exactly
you can't always be nice because yes
the world is not always nice you have to
be able to adapt to the world
yeah sometimes you have to be tough so
like it's it's really cool i'm sitting
here with you because a lot of things
that i've seen
about you and like documentaries and
videos like i've i've felt and i've
lived that too
when you said i was uh i'm walking
towards the ring
you know my heart is beating i'm scared
maybe this guy can knock me out
but the closer i get to the ring i'm
invincible i step into the ring i'm a
god
and that's kind of how i feel like you
know you're scared obviously everybody's
nervous
and a profession you know every
professional is nervous you know maybe
it could be there there maybe it's not
but if you put the work in for that
training camp as soon as you step in the
ring
it feels like you just something takes
over you it's your different entity in
the ring
yeah and i feel that i feel that every
time in the ring
the energy guard whatever yeah i call it
it gives us fear to keep us alive yeah
we didn't have fear we
would run across the street we'd talk
[ __ ] to somebody we know would blow our
[ __ ] brains yeah we would never do
that normally we might spit in a cop
face and you have no fear yeah you know
that's gonna put us in a deep box yeah
and um that's what god gave us fearful
some people's brains are damaged so some
people don't have
it's not their fault they don't have
fear they don't last long either yeah
but um god gave a sister for survival
yeah
you know i used to think when i'm afraid
i just think i was a [ __ ] all the time
because i felt that feeling
yeah that was the um that's my greatest
inspiration my fear
yeah exactly even greatest
qualities for me like even from that
fear i think the fear brings the best
out in you
no time you know even when i'm in
training to the top of the game you
don't let that overwhelm you
you can't lose with it in training camp
sometimes like i'm not
like scared of nobody but you know be
like you got to be sharp maybe this guy
comes these kids hard or whatever
and then you just you do different [ __ ]
you know i mean just out of fear
i'm gonna do head movement i'm gonna do
jab i'm gonna buy you so i'm gonna make
sure everything's perfect so by the time
i get in there
does do you mean yeah i think that makes
yeah i thought about this two-two bike
because you know obviously you're like
you said you're entertainer you're a
fighter but entertainer like you
you get that you know obviously you're
you might you'd hypo fight you do all
that
um part of that too with that happens
that brings more that brings more fear
in you more
more more pressure
you can't talk all that [ __ ] and then
not perform and that's partially why i
feel like even what's mayweather you
know
big 50 of those the fact that he's
always lived in fear
right mike well listen um i feel i feel
sorry for somebody that haven't lived in
fear
you know you know that that's the
healthy fear i'm talking i'm not talking
about fear to have you losing weight
your hair falling out and yeah
getting your heart attack i'm talking
about healthy fear fear of you know of
being called to command you know what i
mean
that kind of fear calling you to do
something
very special that the normal human being
would never try to do
look what we do for a living is our
hands are not even meant to be
punching people that's why they break
all the time this is not meant to be
hitting people
you know but still we made the heart out
of it
you